I'm
oh hey it's that guy that was only funny
on Workaholics
oh yeah
um
it's pretty much what I was gonna say
never because no the other reason
workaholic like the the dude who played
Adam is funny because he's using
righteous gemstones he's hilarious in
that I think he ended up being the only
like he's a big breakout with anyone
yeah because he's done movies with our
modern family and stuff uh water is
eight to eight twenty dollars locals vid
players worse than rumbles so here's the
donation we made twenty dollars because
the locals video wasn't great thanks
nice
we can't lose
um kill the ending ten dollars how can I
send you all a bottle of whiskey made in
my home state I mean if you look at the
comment if you look at like the
description of the video there is a PO
box at the bottom
uh and you can send it there
it's homemade I'm a little worried about
that but you make it yourself no maid in
his home state oh okay so probably like
a local whiskey brand kind of thing and
if somebody could send me vodka made in
Texas it's Tito's just send me tears
it's really Indie vodka called have you
heard of itos it's great it's a little
little brand yeah yeah and Merce likes
this designer thing
called Jameson I heard of it it's very
top shelf I mean it's very very
exclusive if you can get a bottle of it
good luck I like to enjoy Jameson when I
can get my hands on it this is a tiger
thick household
um only Tigers only tiger thick So
speaking of
uh Delia and Eric are talking about uh
Joe Rogan's Comedy Club his new comedy
club now it feels to me like you would
think that
Papa would have been invited right
well let's see the awkwardness uh fellas
you were uh how's Austin
he said it's amazing no but he not
really we talked about off camera it'd
be funny if you came back you showed up
late and they were having a conversation
already because that's what it looks
like right now no no he said it was
great oh by the way Brendan I I know
your burner account you could pretend
it's not you on Twitter but it's you
stop all right it's stupid
be smarter with your burner accounts you
can't also talk like yourself and only
like these kind of videos yeah because
you don't know how to properly talk like
yourself like when people are making fun
of you because then you would actually
be you you better you would be good at
it you would be good at it then yeah
hey look hey Chris I know the tattoo is
new but you know
maybe put a bandage on it for the show
or something put a long sleeve shirt on
it's a little raw just the green room
alone is just amazing it was a Vibe was
it was there a hang no you haven't been
there yet
yeah right no I I need to get out there
no no you haven't been invited because
if Rogan were to go hey come out and see
the reason that they were out there oh
God this is gonna hurt him so much the
reason that they were out there is
because
Rogan or his people ask them to go
perform at his Club because he wanted to
get some hype the reason you haven't
been out there is because let's see
Brandon I've seen your tour schedule you
got plenty of Open dates mm-hmm
[__] you just weren't invited to his
Club I mean I'm sure you will be
eventually because you know it's like
it's like all right fine we have to find
that Brandon know if that's gonna shut
the [__] up about this you know yeah
everybody has a friend like that and you
know we call it we call like a Virgie
friend you know where it's no it's not
what you think it's not what you think
oh it's that he's a piece of [__] oh no
so it is what you think okay yeah it is
what you think it is what you think yeah
by the way when I was texting siraj I
did the voice to text I was like hey man
it's working now just to let you know
like Virgie was saying was happening to
him and other people too but a voice to
text changed it from Virgie to Virgin so
then I started and I wrote Verge he goes
yeah man no problem he goes also
virgie's definitely a virgin and I go he
has kids
um
oh they got these two like one million
views on Tucker's video currently FYI
two TVs for the two different rooms the
lights are in there so when the light
comes on you can change the sound oh
it's got lights and sound in there let
me get out of town I'm sure it's nice
but it just sounds like we've been in
green like a [__] is what it is I
think yeah I think you're right I think
that's where Eric Griffin's just a [__]
hey yeah probably because if you
actually could like if people who know
these kind of things could go in and go
yeah dude they have an entire like uh
like audio visual booth area yeah it's
got you know such and such lights and
you can do all kinds of different
pre-programmed things and then you could
also just do things wire like you know
what I mean but he's just like it got
like the lights and like like sounds and
[__] like that oh thanks Eric appreciate
it whichever room you want to listen to
In The Green Room you get there's a
Bluetooth or somebody can have music in
the Green Room from their phone yeah
they really thought this out yeah yeah
well yeah they're building a comedy club
that they want to succeed yeah a guy
with all the money in the world is
building a comedy club based on his like
30 years experience as a traveling comic
whoa they really thought this out yeah
because he's been doing comedy longer
than three years than you Brendan you
have no [__] idea and also because
Rogan has had experiences where he
probably went you know that one Club up
there and whatever you know in the
Poconos that I do sometimes and there's
no [__] there's nothing to listen to
any music in the [__] Studio I just
have to bring these like air pods yeah
and then I left a pair there and lost
them one time why don't they just have
like that's literally anytime somebody
has done something for years they're
like and how come there's never like a
little TV in a green room I could watch
whatever's going on on this day like
there's so many things that he probably
went I want all this and he probably
said also make it look like the inside
of a toaster remember what he did that
for that and he was like oh boy let me
change it back no one likes this
immediately
I'll be honest that's kind of cool I
kind of like that Vibe and by the way
all three of you morons it's called The
Overlook Hotel you [__] idiots God
damn these these people are dummies yeah
I'm waiting for the Netflix shining to
come out I haven't watched the movie is
it good
the Netflix remake of the show starring
Jenna Ortega in the lead role no alizo
it's going to be Liz and Jenna Ortega
General Ortega is playing the wife
lizzo's wife
I know
Phil to be honest but why is The Shining
he just likes the way that looks I don't
know he's so balls deep in The Shining I
guess I mean it's a classic movie yeah
no it's a great bar in a movie it's
weird you want let's
Chris there's a lot of things you do
that are a little weird but maybe let's
recall things like really quirky you're
like it's [__] you know taking
something you know having money and
taking something that you like and then
you know putting effort into it and
other people would probably enjoy yeah
that's weird you know normally what I do
is I have a burner Snapchat account and
I just talk checks at a questionably age
and you know stuff like that yeah it's
like dude what are you doing you want a
little bar from The Shining like if it
were me personally I would just like
enter into multiple abusive controlling
psychotic relationships with borderline
underage women and then start like just
treating them all like [__] okay okay
but it's okay but enough about kumia
what would he do
thank you
we got a lot in common dude
hey Wacky voice like that call me yeah
it's just funny that to do that to our
Comedy Club but yeah it's a bar that's
that I mean why is Celia kind of I know
why he's cheating on somebody he's
saying it's nice and stuff but he's he's
still well it's kind of weird to do I
haven't seen have you did Leah been on
Rogan since the unpleasantness I don't
think so maybe I'm wrong I I don't watch
Battle of Rogan no because we would have
heard it somebody would have said wow
he's on there again the place looks
amazing I saw the Drone footage but yeah
people love it you see all the boys I've
sold out shows did you see all the boys
there I heard you crushed it by the way
people for whatever reason text DM and
text me when you crush I'm like yeah
yeah
and nobody but notice they're not going
to say yeah people DM me when When you
crush Brendan
all right I'm not there did you do shows
with people there were your shows right
by the way little things it's been a
while since we've really look the
Brandon did they have like a real
headliner doing stuff with you too or
was it just yeah exactly thank you
you're reading
Hotel it's weird it's weird I don't know
you're reading what I'm reading right
like it's a lot of like
I wasn't there why they got to tell me
you killed it's not about me it's not
about me killing you don't kill right
now well I mean
yeah
and uh I did two shows Friday two shows
Saturday and a show Sunday then I did
Kill Tony on Monday did anybody pop on
your shows or no no oh cool so so it's
so so who opened uh I'm sorry
isn't this a conversation you guys
should be having like off here this is a
conversation you and I would have off
here right like hey man you went to that
comedy club how was that oh it was cool
bro like this guy was here why are you
doing this on air in the golden shower
show the golden shower oh somebody uh
free uh free uh pressy dad said salty
cracker was having the same issues with
Rumble not working today so it was it's
probably an issue for everything shocked
I'm shocked
you don't seem it
um this kid Lucas McCreary that's why
they call you a virgin
funny skinny funny dude I'm surprising
David Lucas I was gonna say I'm
surprised you use our boy David for sure
kill her well there's a thing too is
like I think it's also like how quickly
brexit our thing yep yeah our boy it's
so I love them I love that it's so
obvious I think I'm picking up something
simple but it's that obvious but it's
easy to see right we're all seeing this
like we don't have to say you could see
this without even commenting it's our
it's not your there's no when Brennan
succeeds it's his victory when Brendan's
friends succeed it's their Victory it's
super weird like our boy my friend I
have so many friends here are my friends
dude it was the same thing like this is
the difference between the fake La scene
where they're all nice and they've never
ever calls each other out and the New
York scene right like the come Town guys
they literally had a whole bit called
cool Adam because it was literally every
time
like it's like he would name drop he
would always name drop these like
musicians or these Brooklyn like hipster
bands that are like actually like major
label bands and he'd be like yeah man
like I was talking to our friend from uh
CKY the other day he literally brought
up when they had Bam Margera on and he's
like oh yeah the CKY guys man uh yeah
we're all friends with those guys and
like Nick was like why do you do this
why do you do this all the time where
you just co-opt everyone else's friend
oh yeah no there there are there are
boys
stop that but they'd never do that in
L.A nobody would ever stop and go what
is this our boy [__] you ain't even been
in the club there and I will agree with
King all pixels there's nothing more
maddening than comedians talking shop on
a show I don't I understand if you're
talking like you know off the show you
know you both do the same stuff but once
you're on the Luke Gallows Carl Anderson
podcast which is literally called
talking shop that's fine okay because
sex Ferguson might be there it's true
oh I think Rogan wants people to use his
in-house people yeah not just bring in
yeah he's trying yeah well why wouldn't
you use them they're great right no no
but I mean you might have people you
want to yeah true true yeah but he's
like trying to like build something in
the community but it's like you know all
the show while my show was sold out the
other room was sold out right too so
people are really into it it's pop in
there yeah yeah well it's yeah I mean
it's new it's fresh it's the new thing
and here's this guy that is like this
influential guy yeah
and he built this you know playhouse
that you know he's not concerned he's
not concerned about making money he's
concerned about building a good
reputation he's concerned about making
money yeah he's a businessman I'm sure
he also wants a good reputation but you
want a good reputation so you make more
money this is a these are businesses
okay
these are businesses taking care of the
comments like the amount he pays those
Comics yeah
do you think Rogan wants this stuff out
there like when later on when he has to
book people and they'll be like oh I
heard you pay a machine amount yeah you
guys are all talking about him like he's
some money Mark like he's Tony Khan oh
my God that's exactly what it is he's
Tony Khan you're treating him like he's
a pay piggy for Comics if I hey look if
I'm talker I'm talking God damn it if
I'm Rogan and I hear this I pick up the
phone all right I start texting going
hey guys you want to shut the [__] up
about my club and sing I [__] give
give money away because you make him
sound like an idiot you make him sound
like he just wants to give comics
I see why Jim Edward hates comics
he's like really and he's just like he
has a spot I mean I get it maybe he'll
expand and go to like different cities
I mean maybe I doubt it I love how we're
all speculating about this guy's like
[__]
business he's your friend if you here's
the thing here's a perfect example
merch is my friend right if I was I
would never have to do a show and be
like yeah you know I think Mercer you
know I don't know I think it would like
maybe he thinks this about stuff if I
had a question I would just text Marsha
go hey what do you think you're my
friend right this doesn't sound like
he's your friend that you just go hey
bud question about the club you know
instead you're doing this is one of
those also this is this is my joke am I
sorry no as I said if I speculated about
somebody asked me a question about what
your plans were right I would either
already know based on something you told
me I wouldn't just wildly speculate but
I could go oh you have to talk to him
about that before I don't think he'd
want to open up anymore but you know who
the [__] knows this thing takes off you
might want to open up 10 of them kids
and [__] but but but but but this this
isn't about this isn't about they don't
care about talking about the club this
is three minutes of of the joke that I
always say is like never name drop Jay
Moore taught me that this is what that
is it's the what they want to do is
remind people that Joe Rogan is their
friend but the problem is The Golden
Child our show why are your Clips
getting less fused in our Clips because
it was completely Shadow banned because
none of these guys have been on Joe
Rogan and have [__] over a year
um
think about it are the sea flange nobody
on this show has been on Rogan recently
Brendan might have been the most recent
one but but
it's like a fight show yeah it's
Brendan's like the plus one like he's
showing up like Brendan's not invited to
the party but there's a bunch of dudes
coming to the party that are friends
with Brendan and he kind of just comes
in the door with them
it's like if you had that money he's
doing exactly
it's like the the scene here crashed
right the hangout was is done it's not
here very much anymore and he was like
cool I'm gonna do it I miss those days
I'm gonna go build my own yeah that's it
if I had his money that's exactly what I
do oh I'm missing that I'm gonna do this
you know what I'm saying like nobody
else can do that yeah it's definitely
some people can
you're looking rough Chris for a guy
doesn't drink or do drugs
no for real like he's a t-totaler right
you look rough yeah he's sober I bet you
bet you doesn't let people smell his
[__] water bottle
hey what's in what's in that what's in
that water bottle I don't think he
actually does drink or do any of that
stuff that's that it's on brand for his
whole predatory weirdness